so we love to spotlight dads going above
and beyond and today we've got a dad
who's got the whole world dancing for
good
dad program jdp
[Applause]
[Music]
he is a musician in gj but even more
he's the father of two amazingly
beautiful daughters please welcome derek
jones
also known as dj d nice
[Applause]
i'm excited i'm excited i am totally
fangirling out when you first started
club quarantine at the beginning of the
pandemic
all of my friends were texting me and it
was the i mean you had re
rihanna michelle obama oprah everybody
got in on this and it was like
you literally rolled out the carpet of
hope
and community and cool all in one
beautiful burrito that none of us could
get enough
of wow wow i mean you made it sound so
like so much fun it wasn't fun to me
actually i'm a lion i had a fantastic
time i really felt like i was partying
with all of you
um and sharing our love of music with
the world
well we were all so scared and what you
did
was you brought something that felt like
it brought us together
and we were going to an amazing
destination and we're going to do a
dance party with you tonight
joining me club quarantine come on now
we're going to dance together drew
we're going to dance together the first
time i got to go to club quarantine
because all my friends were talking
about it and i was
so jealous i can't help but say um
and i i did it by myself in my bedroom
and i danced around and
honestly i think you literally got
people up
off their couches and out of their beds
and out of the fear
because you you were very current you
did this right away
and i thank you and i'm a mother of two
daughters
and you are a father of two daughters
and i think you really lifted people's
spirits up and we have you for good dads
program
what is it like to raise two girls it's
um
by far the most important responsibility
that i have you know my daughters are
awesome
i'm sure like everyone's kids you know
they're awesome which is the the reason
why i started doing club quarantine
because my my daughter's away to school
um and i was here alone in l.a missing
my family and kids and just felt like
i wanted to do something that kept
people connected i wanted to feel
connected
and what started out as something
literally just for me
it was me wanting to be connected the
very first day
i noticed that it had an impact on just
a small group of people that was in
there the 200 people
and i wanted to do it again and again
and again and um
it we changed the world with music and
it and it all started with like missing
my kids you know which is
i mean now i'm i'm really excited i know
my daughter's watching this right now
she sent me a text message before
jumping on here and she's waiting but
i love you babe tell her we said hello
and
for the good dads program we're going to
recommend that all dads make a playlist
for their kids to dance to
and we're going to see you tonight at 8
p.m for a dance party do nice you make
the world
such a better place and that really is
an understatement
thank you for being here thank you for
having me
you